is morbius a hero or a villain is the
movie a vampire horror film or a
superhero movie with fangs and most
importantly is it any good these are the
six best and six worst things about
mobius
on paper jared leto's michael morbius is
a pretty compelling character suffering
from a rare and usually fatal blood
disease since birth he becomes one of
the world's leading experts on
artificial blood and is even awarded a
nobel prize for his efforts do you need
a doctor i am a doctor
mobius eventually attempts to cure his
condition by splicing his own dna with
that of vampire bats causing him to
develop a number of supernatural
abilities and a deep craving for human
blood most of the film deals with
morbius's internal struggle as he tries
to balance his new violent urges with
the humanitarian ideals that he's always
tried to live by that should be the
formula for an emotionally intense and
nuanced anti-hero story and at times
morbius shows glimpses of just that
michael has contributed a lot of good to
the world and as a viewer you truly
believe that his experiments are largely
motivated by a desire to help others
at the same time morbius can be a pretty
selfish man though his desire to help
the world at large is genuine his number
one motivation seems to be his own quest
for survival there's a lot of rich
potential in this tension between
selflessness and self-preservation and
morbius's vampire transformation could
have been used to explore the
character's inherent duality
michael morbius starts out with a lot of
potential for a nuanced complex
character arc unfortunately the film
wastes no time in squandering that
potential a
time jumps and a poorly written
childhood backstory sequence establish
the character's tragic past in about as
clinical a way as possible as a result
the audience has no real emotional
connection to morbius by the time he
undergoes his transformation there's a
face value sympathy in a man who has
spent his whole life on the brink of
death but the script seems to expect
that premise to be enough and very
little time is spent developing michael
as an actual character is he actually
scared to die what is he living for what
does he want to leave behind these other
kinds of questions that have they've
been addressed on screen could have made
for a deeply textured character perhaps
one more deserving of jared leto's
bizarre method acting techniques instead
viewers are great with a stoic
protagonist with excruciatingly little
substance
one of the best things morbius has going
for it is that the whole aesthetic
surrounding the central character looks
pretty cool he has long vampire hair he
wears a black vampire trench coat and
when he fights he flies around with a
lightning quick fighting style that's
accentuated by some very stylish smoky
swirly effects some might argue that
morbius's powers rely too heavily on cgi
but for the most part that cgi does its
job well morbius is never better than
when the living vampire is in action the
film's first major action sequence which
sees him take down a group of
mercenaries on the ship where he mutates
himself is a definite highlight blending
the from the shadows tension of the
batman movies with the hard-hitting
speed of zack snyder's superman the film
never explains whether the smoke trails
that accentuate morbius's movements are
a side effect of his transformation a
result of his incredible speed or what
but whatever it is it looks pretty cool
the special effects culminate in a
genuinely striking scene where mobius
used this as echolocation to find a
single heartbeat in new york city then
flies to it in a whirlwind of purple and
black this honestly shocking that leto
looks so convincing as mobius
considering that he's nearly twice the
character's age
while the stylish aesthetic created
around the morbius character is quite
effective the rest of the movie suffers
from a myriad of visual problems
cinematographer oliver wood is a
seasoned veteran of his craft and it
would be irresponsible to hold him
solely responsible for the camera work
in morbius but a certain amount of blame
does inevitably fall at his feet what is
perhaps most famous for his work on
contemporary action movies like die hard
2 face off and the original bourne
trilogy though the bourne films received
critical acclaim they've also become
notorious in the years since for
popularizing the use of shaky cam not
every issue with the cinematography and
mobius is due to shaky cam but the
technique is indicative of the larger
problems plaguing the film's cinematic
style nearly every scene is shot with
the same level of intensity at best it's
mildly nauseating at worst it's
practically unwatchable
modern superhero movies seem obsessed
with competing for the longest run time
films like avengers end game spider-man
no way home and the batman all clock in
around the two and a half to three hour
range which can be a big ask for movie
goers of course all those films are also
very well received upon release so it
could be argued that they needed their
extra length to pull everything together
still it's refreshing to see a superhero
movie that keeps things short and sweet
morbius is listed at an hour and 44
minutes and it definitely never dwells
too long on any one scene it's a fast
and furious movie and not just because
of the inclusion of tyrese gibson this
is crazy man
what are you talking about now i'm
sitting there looking at these images
in fact if you compare the final film to
the trailers you'll see that lots of
scenes and lines were removed for the
final cut if sitting through the three
hours that a lot of other movies man
these days is a deal breaker for you
then you may be glad to see how brief
mobius truly is
despite its relatively short run time
morbia still has major pacing problems
it somehow manages to feel both sluggish
and rushed at the same time the film
opens with a beautiful vista shot of
costa rica where michael morbius has
travelled to capture vampire bats after
a brief shot of him using his own blood
as bait the film jumps back in time 25
years for a stilted backstory sequence
explaining his difficult childhood after
that it's another abrupt cut to present
day new york where morbius has revealed
to have successfully captured a whole
swarm of bats off-screen this sort of
rapid fire pacing continues throughout
the film but it gets even more
distracting once a vampire
transformation takes place morbius shows
very little emotion in response to his
monstrous state with only a handful of
loud outbursts to augment his otherwise
stoic demeanor if the movie ever slowed
down for a second it might be able to
humanize morbius and to struggle a bit
more but instead the script keeps
jumping between underdeveloped side
characters and overwritten exposition
there's no time for viewers to catch
their breath much less develop any
tangible emotional attachments perhaps
worst of all this breakneck pace makes
every section of the movie feel the same
the frantic camera work and abrupt scene
transitions make it impossible to
determine which moments are pivotal and
which are supplemental turning the
entirety of morbius into one long
repetitive act
like the vampire for which it's named
morbius is not entirely devoid of life
most of the humor and humanity that can
be found in the film comes from tyreese
gibson and al madrigal who play a pair
of fbi agents investigating mobius's
activities the interplay between
gibson's stone cold persona and
madrigal's deadpan comedy is genuinely
funny with great moments like the latter
bringing a triple blessed vial of holy
water to their interview with the
vampire madrigal and gibson are so
entertaining in fact that it's easy to
envision a better version of morbius but
they play a larger role instead the feds
get relegated to a cts supporting cast
position and their occasional jokes are
ultimately drowned out by the film's
cacophonous self-seriousness
for as good as the fbi agents are in
morbius the other supporting characters
are deeply lacking first and foremost
matt smith's milo based lucy on the
character hunger from the marvel comics
is a terrible villain from the moment
he's introduced it's painfully obvious
until eventually turn evil when michael
tells his friend this isn't you it's
almost laughable this is clearly the
only thing milo was ever written to be
equally disappointing as michael's
romantic subplot with dr martine
bancroft played by adria arjuna the
actress does her best with a script that
is constantly working against her but
her efforts just aren't enough
the greatest trick that morbius pulls is
showing you glimpses of a better movie
that could have been the opening title
card fades in over a cool synthwave
graphic of hard lines and bright pinks
teasing a retro aesthetic that never
comes to fruition the hard-boiled humor
of the fbi agents hints at poppy noir
but that toe never gets enough of a
foothold to influence the rest of the
film and of course there are plenty of
dark corridors to evoke the horror genre
which morbius pulls from heavily in the
moments where the stylistic touches are
strongest morbius can be a pretty fun
movie unfortunately the movie refuses to
fully commit to any of its more
interesting aesthetics languishing
mostly in dreary exposition and ripping
off scenes from better movies a shot of
michael being swarmed by vampire bats in
his lab is a particularly egregious
instance of this with a backing score
that elicits memories of han zimmer's
batman begin score unfortunately that's
a comparison morbius would probably be
better off not even attempting to make
it's not who i am underneath
but what i do
that defines me
though it occasionally evokes other
genres morbius is a superhero movie
through and through but even in that
space the film feels about two decades
too late rather than those more recent
entries in the genre morbius is easier
to compare to early 2000s movies like
ben affleck's daredevil from the clunky
dialogue and overall angsty tone to the
flat side characters morbius is a movie
that feels stuck in the past swooping in
from an era when superhero films were
bad more often than they were good and
before stars like robert downey jr
proved that comic book exposition didn't
have to sound dorky on camera if morbius
leaned more into its retro vibe if it
allowed more of the crow in and less of
ghost rider perhaps sony would have had
something instead we're left with a
series of questions about how a movie
like morbius got made in 2022
like most superhero movies of the modern
era morbius peppers some teasers for the
future with its end credits there are
two post-credits scenes in the film both
of which focus on the return of michael
keaton's adrian tombs character from
spider-man homecoming because keaton is
a fantastic actor and because homecoming
is so beloved it's undeniably fun to see
tombs brought back into the fold at what
cost
great question while the cameo is fun at
first it also comes with its share of
problems for starters seeing him at the
end of morbius mostly reminds viewers of
a much better movie then there's a
matter of how he actually appears in the
mobius universe which is confusing to
say the least the first credit scene
shows the sky over new york being
fractured clearly referencing the
multiverse spell from spider-man at no
way home however that spell previously
only brought characters from other
realities into the mcu not the other way
around so why does tombs teleport to
michael morbius's world how does he get
a new vulture suit without chitari
technology is there even a spider-man in
sony's spider-man universe these are
confusing questions to leave audiences
with at the end of a movie but given
that the movie is morbius they're a
welcome distraction
from top to bottom morbius is a failure
it ruins all efforts of horror and
tension by rushing through every scene
it kneecaps a potentially interesting
protagonist by leaving him cold and
underdeveloped it is an hour and 44
minutes of messy plotting clumsy
dialogue and nauseating cinematography
and it ends with one of the most
egregious cgi slugfest in the history of
superhero cinema the venom movies might
not be masterpieces but they embrace
their campy tone in a way that at least
makes them entertaining to watch morbius
on the other hand is the worst kind of
bad movie the kind that's so messy and
body constructed that it feels like a
chore just to keep watching it sony
clearly has high hopes for their
interconnected spider-man universe but
as the first proper expansion into that
shared continuity morbius is a colossal
disappointment this movie is a total
disappointment no thought went into it
no effort went into it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]